Britain once ruled the biggest empire in
human history. At its peak, it spanned a
quarter of the globe and ruled over
hundreds of millions of people. For
some, the empire remains a symbol of
national pride.
>> But in recent years, there has been a
resurgence of criticism of the empire
across the Caribbean, Africa, Asia, and
in Britain itself. and we demand an
apology and reparations.
>> Critics say the empire was built on
racial discrimination, stolen land, and
the mass murder and enslavement of
millions. So, who [music] gets to tell
the story of Britain's empire? And
should Britain have a reckoning with its
sorted imperial past? My guest tonight
is emeritus regist professor of moral
and pastoral theology at Oxford
University, Nigel Bigger. He argues that
the critics of the British Empire
overstate its vices while ignoring its
many virtues. I'm Meredi Hassan and
tonight I'll go head-to-head with Nigel
Bigger, a conservative peer. I'll
challenge him on his defense of empire
and colonialism and his arguments
against reparations for slavery.
[music]
Tonight, I will also be joined by three
experts. Ginda Bombra, professor of
historical sociology in the department
of international relations at the
University of Sussex. Kojo Karam,
professor of law and history at the
University of Lubbor, and Lawrence
Goldman, fellow and tutor in modern
history at St. Peters College, Oxford
University,
[applause]
Nigel Bigger, thank you so much for
joining us on Headto-Head tonight. The
British Empire was the biggest in
history. And under the empire, millions
died in famines from Ireland to India,
in massacres from Malaya to Kenya, in
concentration camps in South Africa. The
list goes on and on, as you know better
than me. But you say you felt compelled
as an ethicist, not as a historian, to
write your book, Colonialism, a moral
reckoning, because you say there is
quote a fairer, more positive story to
be told about the British Empire than
the anti-colonialists want us to hear.
Briefly, just to kick us off, what is
that story?
>> So, the first thing to say, Medie, is
that empire and slavery and racism are
universal phenomena practiced in every
continent by people of every skin color.
uh you can't find any 400year uh long
state such as the British Empire was
that doesn't contain very bad stuff and
you've listed some of them there. But
the British Empire chalked up some some
major liberal and humanitarian
achievements that uh uh I don't want us
to forget. Uh for example, the British
were among the first peoples in the
history of the world to abolish slavery.
then used imperial power for a century
and a half to suppress slavery from
Brazil to New Zealand. Um the British uh
also the British Empire also uh uh
committed itself to fighting the
massively murderous genocidal regime in
Nazi Berlin in 1939. And for 12 months
between May 1940 and June 41, the empire
offered Nazi Germany the only military
resistance with the sole exception of
Greece. And the empire has produced,
according to the World Value Survey
2023, three of the least racist
countries on Earth, Britain, Australia,
and Canada in sharp contrast to Russia,
China, and Iran.
>> In your book, Colonialism and Moral
Reckoning, you list various motivations
you say drove the British Empire like
the lure of adventure, a desire to make
peace and establish self-government. You
say there's nothing wrong with these
innocent uh in some cases you say
admirable intentions. I do wonder
though, for example, did Ceil Roads, the
British colonial founder of Rhdesia, did
he have good intentions when he said he
preferred African land to Africans, who
he called the n-word, and when he wrote,
"Africa is still lying ready for us. It
is our duty to take more territory. More
territory simply means more of the
Anglo-Saxon race, more of the best, the
most human, the most honorable race the
world possesses."
>> Yeah. So, I don't defend uh Cecil Roads.
Um I would I wouldn't present him as a
poster boy of the British Empire. you
have defended him.
>> Well, partial defense uh he wasn't South
Africa's Hitler. He didn't commit
genocide in in South Africa. Was he
racist? Um well, uh if he was, he was a
racist who who opposed the the removal
of the vote from black South Africans in
in Cape Colony. Um and his his famous
road scholarships uh in his will he made
clear these scholarships were to be
granted regardless of race. people
disagree about what he meant by that.
>> But within within four years of his
death, uh the first uh African-American
road scholar was appointed. Uh so uh
Roads, I made made quite clear, Roads is
a is a mixed bag. He wasn't a saint, but
he wasn't a devil. He was a buccaneer.
It's a very general assessment of a man
who's considered to be a kind of deeply
dishonorable person in the way he led
his life and the way he had when you say
he wasn't a saint, wasn't a wasn't a
sinner, wasn't wasn't a devil. I mean
that could apply to anyone in this room
and people in this room haven't said
ridiculous things about natives should
be subjected to British rule. I mean
it's a very soft assessment. I mean I
could you know we wouldn't say that
about other dictators, tyrants, killers
throughout history. And you take this
approach to a lot of colonial leaders.
>> Uh part well in in Rose's case I'm
responding to the kinds of things that
>> those who are clamoring for Rose's
statue in Oxford to fall. South Africa's
Hitler guilty of genocide white
supremacist. None of those things are
simply true. There are elements of truth
in them, but not simply true. Um, so um,
no, I so I do defend Rose, but it's it's
a critical defense.
>> It's a weird defense, though. It's a
defense take. You've said twice now he's
not South Africa's Hitler. You mentioned
the Nazis a couple of times.
>> Well, that's because his critics do.
>> But in the book, I think about a dozen
times you say the British Empire was not
Nazi Germany. Um, which I'm not going to
argue with you tonight about,
>> but many do.
>> Many do, but it's a very low bar to say
we were not the Nazis, right? for as as
a moral philosopher, I'm sure you
understand that point.
>> I get that.
>> And I would also add, by the way, the
Nazis themselves were fans of the
British Empire, as you know. I mean,
Hitler said we should learn from the
English. Hitler said he had sincere
admiration for the immeasurable
colonizing work of the British Empire.
Not a great endorsement, I would say.
>> No, no, indeed. Let me just just make
clear what the um what the appeal to to
Nazism, what part it plays in in the
argument against the British Empire. The
argument against the British Empire is
um if you look through history, it it
contained both good and bad. Okay. Uh
but what the critics say is well it
doesn't matter how many uh bridges the
the the British built in India or canals
they developed whatever it was
essentially racist essentially genocidal
in the same way that it doesn't matter
the fact that that Hitler had a hand in
developing the Volkswagen or whatever
Avitz
there there's no compensation for Avitz
and all I'm saying is okay the British
Empire did contain both good and bad but
there was nothing akin to to the
massively uh racist genocidal intent of
building
>> as a moral philosopher and theologian,
you would agree that not being the Nazis
shouldn't be the bar,
>> right? You can be an evil empire and
still not be the Nazis. Saddam Hussein
could say, "Yeah, I gassed the Kurds,
but I'm not Hitler."
>> We wouldn't we would still say Saddam
was an evil man.
>> But the the point is uh the argument
made by the critics is the British
Empire was essentially evil. And I say
no, it wasn't essentially evil. It was
it was a mixture of good and bad. Uh
there were elements of racism also ele
And a lot of historians of Empire do not
say essentially evil. They point out the
sheer quantity of evil they've done that
we don't talk about. Nigel, you teach at
Oxford. I studied at Oxford. I went to
school in the UK. I think people in this
audience in London would agree in this
country. You're taught about the Tudtor
and the Nazis. I can tell you about how
many wives Henry VII had. I was not
taught about the Mao massacre. I was not
taught about the Amritza massacre. I was
not taught about British concentration
camps in South Africa. It's actually the
opposite of what you're saying. We've
actually covered up our rather sorded
and evil imperial past. Uh
>> I don't think that's fair. I mean I mean
for God's sake a
>> you think most British people know about
all those massacers. I just
>> No, but most people know no any history
at all. For example, if we learn about
about the 150 years, mainly 150 years in
which some British people were involved
in enslaving Africans. That's fine. Can
we also hear about the abolition
movement? Yes. And
>> I promise that tonight we're going to
talk about slavery right now. Just on
roads. It's interesting you said he's
not South Africa's Hitler. Hitler was a
fan of Roads, the man you're saying is a
mixed man. Gerbles praised him by name.
>> May maybe Hitler was a fan of Mozart.
That doesn't make Mozart bad.
>> No, but he but maybe he was a fan of
Mozart. Well, it's a great it's a great
line, but let's just think that through.
Maybe he was a fan of Mozart for his
music. And maybe he was a fan of Roads
for being an imperialist who killed
non-white people.
Um [applause]
it's not clear to me maybe what that
says what that says about roads. I mean
the viewer
>> pretty bad guy I would say. I mean the
problem you have Nigel is this is what
you do in the book. You say I'm looking
at good and evil but when you look at a
lot of colonial leaders you you present
them in the best possible light. Let me
give you an example. And people accuse
you of cherrypicking. You know this
because you've responded to your critics
at length in the book. Um, for example,
you praise a colonial leader like the
first mockquis of Hastings who was
governor general of India and you quote
him saying that he wanted to promote the
quote happiness of the vast population
of the country and you praise him for
saying that great line that's a quote
from his diary which you quote from in
that same diary he says that Hindus in
India are limited to quote mere animal
functions with no higher intellect than
a dog might be supposed to capable of
attaining. Strange that you didn't
include that quote in your book. Um I
didn't include that quote but you can
find other quotes similar to it. So I
don't deny
>> I mean it completely undermines the idea
of the Marcus Hastings as some great
believer in egalitarianism and racial
equity.
>> Not uh not entirely medi because most of
us are are moral mixtures and we're not
consistent. I don't I don't condone the
stuff you've just read out from his
diary. Um and I people can read the book
and find that I caught other people
saying equally aborant racist things. Uh
my argument is yes, the British Empire
contained racism as as does any human
society. And and and let's be clear
here, racism was not was not an
invention of the British or Europeans.
Lots of of of Africans have racist views
of other Africans. Uh um uh um medieval
Arabs had racist views of both Europeans
and Africans. Uh Gandhi was disparaging
about Africans. So let's be clear,
racism is not a peculiar British thing.
It's aborant. And and my point is racism
was was uh not you you cannot say that
the British Empire was essentially
racist because they there were also
anti-racist impulses as well. And the
whole of the abolition movement which
became widely popular in this country in
the late 1700s was premised on the the
on the basic equality of all people
under God regardless of race. And that
>> you're defending the empire by citing a
lot of anti-imperialists but as I said
we will come to slavery just on
colonialism and racism. You mentioned
again you said lots of other societies
were racist. Gandhi was racist. Africans
are racist. First of all, we're talking
about the British Empire. So that's one
issue.
>> Yeah, but let's let's put that in
context.
>> But you're a moral theologian, so you're
supposed to describe actions and judge
actions objectively independently. The
what aboutism is something you find on
the playground. Well, miss, I hit him,
but he hit me and that kid hit that kid.
If you're evaluating whether the British
Empire was good or evil, you should
evaluate on its merits.
I'm quite clear that racism from
whatever quarter is is morally wrong. Uh
what I'm against is picking out the
British and saying these people were
were
>> the British. We had the biggest
extraordinarily racist because it isn't
true.
>> I mean you're you're using straw man
arguments extraordinary race. I don't
know what that metric is but we had the
biggest empire in the world. We were
involved in the slave trade. We
conquered countries like multiple
countries across the world. Uh ran them
almost as dictatorships. And the
colonial leaders did speak in racist
terms. I've only quoted two. We could
quote about 20 more. There is a lot of
what aboutism in the boat. you
seem to justify.
>> What's wrong? What's wrong with what
aboutism?
>> What is wrong with what aboutism? Well,
I'll give you an example. You say, for
example, the first opium war in which
the British kill thousands of Chinese
people. You say that war was wrong. You
say in the book, you say it was wrong.
It was unjust. But then you add straight
away in the just a couple of lines later
that those Chinese deaths at the hands
of the British in the 19th century and I
quote you fade into insignificance when
compared to the millions killed by Mao
in China a century later. What has one
got to do with the other? Mao killing
Chinese people in the 20th century
doesn't make it okay for the British to
kill Chinese people in the 19th century.
How is that a moral assessment?
>> The connection is this. uh the the
communist government in China uh uses uh
the the um the period when when European
powers and British powers were
exploiting China to to excite Chinese
nationalism and the the communist
government in in Beijing completely
ignores the fact that that that that Mao
presided over uh uh the death of Chinese
the death of Chinese on a much larger
scale.
>> It's not a moral point though. So why
did you add the caveat that pales into
insignificance compared to
>> to make clear medi that this was not
extraordinary?
>> But that's not what morality is about. I
mean no Niger it's not just China. I
mean throughout the book through I read
this book throughout the book you kind
of go halfway there and then you can't
help yourself. You say the British
Empire was bad but it wasn't the Nazis.
The first Opium War was bad but Mao was
worse. You say famines happened in India
under the imperial watch but the famines
happened after independence too. You say
the camps in Kenya were bad, but then
you say, "But the Soviet goolags were
worse." You do that throughout the book.
You can't bring yourself to just say,
"This was really bad."
>> As a Britain, I'm saying this was bad.
>> Well, you do that page,
>> you do it tonight.
>> Page 276, you will you will find a whole
list of the bad things over which the
British Empire presided.
>> I'm chuckling because I had a feeling
that you were going to say page 276
because you wrote a postcript and every
time someone criticizes you, you say,
"Look at page 276." It's like your one
page out of 400 pages where you list all
the crimes and it's your go-to move to
say page 276
>> because page 276 summarizes what the
previous 250 pages have said. It's not
just the only place.
>> So, can you do it tonight? Can you
criticize something the British Empire
did as evil without any qualification
caveat if but what about
>> uh slavery uh um disproportionate
violence uh sometimes the theft of land?
Um uh uh uh the most destructive thing
probably was the spread of disease which
was inadvertent. Um
>> you just did it. You just did it. You
just did it in front of our eyes.
[laughter]
>> Well, tell tell me tell me um um um the
the COVID uh um the COVID epidemic
killed 7 million people.
>> Okay.
>> It it it it originated in China.
>> Did the Chinese intend to kill 7 million
people?
>> You've literally just made my point. Why
are we talking about CO? You couldn't
bring yourself to just say it was really
bad on the British.
>> The point has to do with the the uh the
the the moral quality of uh of an act uh
depends on intention. There lots of
things we do that have bad effects. So
>> I agree with you on that. We agree. We
agree.
>> So so Europeans Europeans
brought diseases to North America and
Australia as did Indonesian fishermen
from Indonesia to northern Australia uh
which had devastating effects on native
peoples. No one intended to do it. No
one can be blamed for it.
>> I agree with your intent. But when you
carry out a massacre, it like in
Amritsa, that's intent. When you carry
out torture in Kenya and you say, "We're
going to do this quietly," that's
intent.
>> As I admit in the book,
>> Okay, good. So, we can condemn what
happened in Kenya as a evil stain on
British history as part of
>> Well, it depends what you mean, but the
that the the
>> the torture of people in the
>> the the clubbing to clubbing to death of
of 11 DTNAs by African warders at Hol
Camp, yes. was was very bad and the
authorities are responsible for that.
Yep.
>> Great. I love it when we agree. In the
conclusion of your book, Colonialism, a
moral reckoning, you offer your readers
a tally of the evils of British
colonialism as well as a of course
credit column in the British Imperial
Ledger. Basically, wh why why do you say
of course I'll tell you you seem to be
skeptical.
>> I am. And I'll tell you why.
>> You summarize the pros and cons, the
good and the evil,
>> and then you say you're not keeping
score. You say very explicit. Is that
still the case that you're not you're
not scoring them?
>> I don't say that.
>> Uh you say the where's it gone? Let me
just pull up the exact quote. You say um
whatever the debit column of British
colonialism, there's a credit column two
of which any fair ethical assessment
must take into account the goods and
evils that the empire caused
intentionally or not of such different
kinds that they cannot be measured
against one another.
>> The different keeping score. So I I I
keep score, but I say you can't weigh
these up.
>> You can't say one's longer or better
than the other.
>> Tell me how.
>> Is that your position?
>> Tell me how. No, I'm asking the
question.
>> Can't be done.
>> It can't be done. So then why did you go
on a right-wing podcast and say that the
credit column is longer?
>> Because on the page it is.
[applause]
Uh uh let me be clear. Uh on the on the
page there's a long a longer list of the
good stuff. On the matter of whether you
can weigh these things up, you can't do
it.
>> So you you were just talking about the
physical pages that take it up. You
weren't trying to imply on a right-wing
podcast in 2023 that the credit column
is longer for the British Empire.
>> Why is it relevant your the Pope was
rightwing? What's got to do with
anything?
>> Oh, I think because you were talking to
a host who was much more in agreement
with you and you were much more honest
about what your actual view is, which is
you think the British Empire did more
good than evil.
>> You No, I didn't say that. You you have
um um I've said I made it perfectly
clear. I don't think you can weigh out
goods and evils in that fashion. So, the
point you're making is actually beside
the point. Even if we accept that a
column is longer and you're saying you
don't think it's longer, you were
talking about number of pages.
>> It was longer physically in the
>> physically. You're talking physically.
Okay. But let me get to my question. How
does that morally justify any of the
evil side of the column?
>> It doesn't.
>> It doesn't. Right.
>> Well, but name Okay. It doesn't. No, it
doesn't justify it. But naming any any
state, as I say, any long-standing state
uh that doesn't preside over bad stuff.
And and
>> but isn't that But isn't that a problem
then as a moral philosophy?
>> Yeah. Well, yeah.
>> Like how do we judge the evil people in
history? They'll all come up with some
defense of some good thing they did.
>> No.
>> Or do we just give the British Empire
that pass?
>> No, we don't. We give No, I and I don't
give it that pass. Uh what I say is the
the empire contained both both these
things different times. Um
>> I mean millions of people died because
of the British Empire under the rule of
the British Empire over the course of
hundreds of years.
>> Um yeah.
>> Yeah. So I can say that is a great evil
just as I could look at the Nazis and
say millions of people died in Nazis.
Now we can play pedentry around who was
essentially racist or not. But in terms
of killing people, the British Empire
killed a lot of innocent people. And
many of us would argue that should be a
bigger source of shame and focus than
the fact that yes, they built railway
stations. It only matters whether the
British Empire did good or evil in its
own terms.
>> You have to pick. Are you a historian or
are you an ethicist? Can you keep
jumping around?
>> I'm a bit of both. Uh so so my view is
that British Empire presided over both
good and evil. and I make I do the best
I can at the end and I and explain what
my what my overall argument is.
>> Let's go to our panel of experts who've
been waiting patiently here. Guminda
Bambra is a professor of historical
sociology at the department of
international relations the University
of Sussex, editor of the forthcoming
book, The Modern World After
Colonialism. Uh Ginda, you've read
Nigel's book. I know. Uh in his
introduction, he does say he sets out to
paint a historically accurate and fairer
picture of the British Empire. Did he do
it in your view?
>> Not in my view. No.
>> What's your central objection to what
you've heard from Nigel tonight? Well, I
think one of the first things we have to
take issue with is the way in which
Nigel constructs the very idea of empire
and this argument that he makes that
empires have existed across human
societies across all time and that all
empires are effectively the same sort of
phenomenon. And I would argue that we
need to think about empires quite
differently. There is a significant
difference between empires of
incorporation which included empires
such as the Ottoman, the Chinese, the
Mughal and European empires of
extraction which were effectively the
British, the French and the Dutch. And
one of the ways in which we can think
about the differences between the two is
the way in which they relate to
questions of food scarcity that occur
because food scarcity occurs across all
human societies at different times. the
British Empire and if we compare it with
the Mughal Empire because it's the same
territory the same populations there was
no significant famine that created death
under the Mughal Empire which ruled for
over 400 years under the British Empire
within India within in just with when
the East India Company came into power
they presided over a famine in Bengal
which killed over 10 million people out
of a population of 30 million and they
collected more taxes at the same time
they had never been a famine under
Mughal rule within Bengal. And the next
time there was a significant famine in
Bengal was when the British government
were directly in control during the
Second World War where three million
died.
>> Let me bring in Lawrence Goldman who is
a fellow and tutor in modern history at
St. Peters College Oxford, former editor
of the Oxford Dictionary of National
Biography. Lawrence, how do you respond
to what you've heard tonight?
>> Well, I'm fascinated by the moralism
that you show Medi and that I think the
audience shows because I don't think
moralism has a place in these arguments,
if I may say so. If you read history as
a record of whether people are just or
evil, you're not doing anything at all.
You're certainly not reading history.
You're imposing upon the complexity of
human civilization
not only the wrong categories because
every society, every civilization is
evil in some ways and good in others.
And you're also, if I may say so, you
are projecting onto the past your own
contemporary morality. If you think
about racism for a moment, most of human
history has been dominated by people who
have thought in racial terms, who have
divided the world and the peoples that
they governed according to their races.
It is absolutely ubiquitous. It is
absolutely normal. And we of course
because we now live in anti-racist
societies we are simply projecting onto
the past. They would not understand us
medi it would be completely ahistorical.
So I asked the audience to think
historically and not moralistically.
>> So the problem Lawrence is is that Nigel
specifically wrote a book saying he
wanted to make a moral assessment of
empire. So if you have a problem with
the morality side of things you should
take it up with Nigel not me. That was
the goal of the book. Uh, in terms of in
terms of what you said about [applause]
in terms of what you said about
projecting onto the past, I hear that
argument a lot and I take your point
about racism and where cultural
attitudes go. But killing lots of
people, I'm pretty sure they thought
that was wrong in 1850, 1750, 1650,
murdering and massacring women and
children, I think they thought that was
wrong at the time as well. remarkable in
the history of the British Empire that
at a certain point in the 19th century
they began to think rather differently
about the use of violence and they
wanted for example
>> because they set up concentration camps
in South Africa straight after that
>> perhaps but but but what they wanted to
do was trade now the British Empire as
you present it is one long exercise in
the same thing but as a historian I put
it to you that it's not a free trade
empire in the 19th century is really
about commercial integration.
>> Let me bring in let me bring in Kojo
Karam who's a professor of law and
history at the University of Lurra
author of uncommon wealth Britain and
the aftermath of empire. Uh Nigel says
many of the intentions behind the people
setting up the empire were admirable in
some ways. People wanted to establish
self-government. He says you just heard
Lawrence say a free trade empire. What
is wrong with that view of the empire in
your opinion?
>> Well I think what we need to do is
actually look at what was said by some
of the people who set up the empire.
What's really fortunate about the
British Empire is so much of the heavy
lifting of empire wasn't done by the
British state, but was actually done by
a number of private chartered companies.
And what you can see in their charters
is their objective for why they started
the extraction of wealth in those
countries. And that is to maximize
profits for their shareholders. whether
they introduced some cultural practices
or played a little football with the
natives as part of that project is not
the objective of these institutions. We
can look at the historical conversation
that happened not subsequently rewriting
history but at the time look at the
words of um to say if I said to you at
the moment the idea that the
colonization of the Caribbean was the
great source of wealth and power in
Britain. You might think that that's
been written by a CLR James or an Eric
Williams or a Walter Rodney. No, that's
Edmund Burke, the father of English
conservatism. Until very recently, it
was common sense that the British Empire
gained most of its wealth from the
colonization of um of of the colonies
and it's in fact a lot of the
revisionism that I think is being done
right now.
>> Nigel, do you want to respond to Koji or
Gabinda? He says revision.
>> Let me just start with with Kojio since
that's freshing my mind. So, so could
you on that on that last point, you're
quite right. I there are there are some
economic historians who reckon that the
contribution of slave trading and
slavery to Britain's industrialization
was I think Eric Williams said enormous.
Others say central. Um most e economic
historians uh um that I know about say
no, it was somewhere between small and
modest. the the the greatest living
historian of transatlantic slavery,
David Eltus. And I I say that because um
Henry Gates um the African-American
historian at Harvard rates Eltus as as
the as the most authoritative. He uh
uses the word trivial in terms of the
contribution of of slave trading
slavery.
One thing we need to make clear on that
issue. Anyone who makes an unqualified
claim that slave trading and slavery
made an enormous or central contribution
to uh British industrial prosperity is
not telling the whole truth because that
is highly controversial.
>> Okay. We are as I mentioned earlier we
are going to talk slavery after the
break. Do you want to deal with Git's
point about the the you treat all
empires the same and the British Empire
in many ways was worse than other
empires?
>> Well, I I I know the empire took took
different forms. I don't accept the
simple description of British Empire as
extractive. Uh um partly because uh um
the the
population of India during British rule
increased by almost three times which
implies some level of increasing
prosperity. Uh the the uh the area of
cultivatable land in India increased
eight times under the British. Uh so I
don't deny there were uh um um instances
of exploitation and extraction. But to
characterize the whole of the empire in
those terms is simply wrong because the
empire gave indigenous peoples
opportunities they've never had.
>> Just to clarify, I mean you mentioned
the population. There is also studies
done. Journal of World Development did a
study that between 1890 and 1920 there
were 50 million excess deaths in India.
We will continue this discussion.
There's more to go. We've we've
mentioned slavery a few times uh
tonight. We will go back to our panel.
We will hear more from Nigel in part two
of Headto-Head when we come back with
Nigel Bigger to talk about his other
book, Reparations, Slavery, and the
Tyranny of Imaginary Guilt. Don't go
away.
[applause]
Welcome back to Headto Head on Alazer.
My guest tonight is Nigel Bigger, moral
theologian, conservative peer, author of
the book Reparations, Slavery, and the
Tyranny of Imaginary Guilt. Nigel, first
half we talked about colonialism and
empire in your first book, Colonialism
and moral reckoning. Let's talk about
slavery, which you write about in your
colonialism book. You also write it
about in your book this year, uh,
reparations. Uh, you've said slavery has
come in a variety of forms throughout
history. It's existed since time
immemorial. You say, quote, "It is
obvious that slavery is wrong, but then
you go on to say in the same paragraph
that there could be good and bad forms
of it." Can you tell the audience here
what a good form of slavery is?
Well, for for example, domestic slavery
in in the Islamic world was a lot less
inhumane than cattle slavery on the
sugar plantations of of the West Indies,
as I'm sure you'd agree. And in the
Islamic world uh some slaves could rise
to very high positions of political
power. Uh so I I even though I think all
slavery uh in which uh human beings are
the property of someone else and have no
rights whatsoever is wrong for that
reason. Nevertheless, that can take
different forms, some of which are a lot
less inhumane.
>> So, what you made to say is there are
less worse forms. There are no good
forms of slavery. Because you use the
word good, and that jumped out to me as
a moral philosopher, you would say
there's such a thing as a good.
>> No, I No, I I made perfectly clear I
think slavery as such is wrong for the
reason I've said so. Yes, less worse.
>> By the way, I noticed you mentioned in
the book, and you just said a moment
ago, Islamic slavery.
>> And yet throughout the books, both
books, I never see you refer to what the
British or the Portuguese did as
Christian slavery. Why? Um, [applause]
so the the use of the word Islamic there
is is not is not referring to to
religion as such. It's referring to a
culture. I could have said Arab, but I'm
not quite clear whether there were uh as
it were Muslim peoples who were involved
in slavery who weren't Arab. So I use
either term.
>> But you but you would have be happy to
use the phrase Christian slavery.
>> Uh yes I would. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yes I
would. You've argued in your book
reparations, slavery and the tyranny of
imaginary guilt that Britain has already
essentially paid uh penance for slavery
by abolishing it and later fighting
against the slave trade. Uh putting
aside the arguments around practicality
and logistics how you would do
reparations. Can we part that for a
moment? As an ethicist, do you even
believe there is a moral case still for
Britain to offer some form of
reparations for its big role in the
slave trade? Uh no.
>> Why?
>> Uh several reasons. Uh uh first of all
um as I say, slavery was a uni universal
institution. Uh secondly, uh lots of
peoples were involved in the
transatlantic slave trade, not least
Africans. So if we're going to have a as
it were an accounting of who is what,
then the African nations need to be
taken into account as well. Uh third,
the British were among the first peoples
in the history of the world to abolish
both the trade and and institution. Then
spent both money and lives suppressing
it worldwide. Uh does that make up for
what was done to the um millions of
African slaves in the West Indies or the
Southern American colonies? No, it
doesn't. There's no way we can. I mean,
those people are dead. Um the best the
British could do was to stop it and then
to try and stop other people enga
engaging in it.
>> Let's I just want to unpack because you
said a couple of points there. uh in
terms of the African countries, we
talked about this in part one. That is
what what aboutism from a moral point of
view, whether Britain should uh offer
some form of reparations or apology for
slavery is irrelevant what other people
do. No, it's not.
>> You're responsible for your own actions.
>> No, it's not. Why?
>> It's not. Uh um by all means, Britain
should should u um acknowledge
responsibility for that. Um so should
African countries and they don't. So
it's a matter of fairness.
>> That's not true.
>> It's a matter of fairness. That's not
true.
>> The African Union The African Union.
>> Hold on. Hold on. You said African
countries have not. That is factually
untrue,
>> comprising lots of
>> Well, we're not in the European Union as
people know anymore. So, let's forget
about unions.
>> African Union.
>> A few weeks ago, had said that it plans
to to submit a bill to Britain for
reparations for slavery when most
African lots of African countries
especially in the West Africa were
involved.
>> You're you're not dealing with the
central point, which is you said African
countries have not apologized or not
involved in some form of reparations.
Uganda and Benin have both formally
apologized. Why can't we follow them and
do the same?
>> Apologize. Okay. for a formal state
apology. Why can't the British
government do it?
>> Because we apologized
ago by stopping it and suppressing it.
>> That's not an apology.
>> It's much more than an apology.
>> Nigel, you are a professor. You are a
professor of moral theology. And when I
hear you speak, if I went out if if if
me and all my neighbors killed everyone
in the local area, hold on, let me
finish my analogy. Let's pretend that
I'm your student in class. Here's my I'm
making my pitch to you as a professor.
If me and all my friends killed everyone
in the local area, we constantly killed
and kidnapped people in the local area
and then I stopped doing it and I then
made all my neighbors stop doing it.
You're telling me that that any kind of
justice for the people I killed or
kidnapped, that they've had any kind of
accountability, that I've made up for
what I did just by stopping doing it.
Stopping committing a crime, you don't
get a prize for stopping committing a
crime. You okay, [applause] you tell me
where am I wrong? Um, morally, where am
I wrong?
I think I think if if you're among the
first peoples in the history of the
world to stop doing something that is
very common uh I think you should get
some credit for that especially if it
cost you and I think you should also get
credit for spending a century and a half
suppressing it from Brazil to New
Zealand at at cost. Um can you make up
for what happened to those people then?
No, you can't. Can we make up for what
happened to to the to the medieval surfs
who were exploited or the early
industrial workers who was talking? No,
we can't.
>> Hold on. Hold on. We did lose people as
you say. You keep mentioning the cost.
Several hundred uh some say more than a
thousand British sailors were involved
in sacrificed their lives and and that
is undeniably true. Um 3 million slaves
were taken by the British Empire across
the Atlantic. 300,000 of them or more
died just crossing over the Atlantic.
Whatever we did to cancel it out pales
into insignificance with the original
crime. And when you say talk about, you
know, we can't do anything about it.
They're already dead. Funny that we
managed to find 20 million pounds at the
time, which was equivalent to 40% of the
government budget to compensate the
slave owners. We compensated the slave
owners, but not the slaves or the
victims of slavery.
>> And the reason for that,
>> how is that not a huge moral wrong
morally?
>> Uh, no, it wasn't morally wrong. Partly
because that was required to get
abolition through the British
Parliament. had it not been
>> that's Nigel bigger the conservative
peer speaking that's a politician that
is not a moral assessment
>> well the the
>> morally that's irrelevant what was
needed to go through parliament
>> no no no medie no no no uh uh if you
want to get slavery abolished that was
the political cost and if you don't pay
that cost then slavery gets extended I
think that was a that was a justifi a
morally justifiable political compromise
the other reason for paying compensation
to to to the owners of of of slaves
was to enable slave plant to enable
sugar plantations to to remain viable
businesses after abolition. Uh why? Yes,
of course, so that so that investors
could could continue to to make make a
profit, but also uh so that emancipated
slaves would have some means of earning
a wage. So why can't people today in the
Caribbean for example the CARACOM as you
know the Association of Caribbean States
they're asking for you know what their
number one request is in their 10-point
list of reparations a formal apology
that costs us nothing. Why can't we do
that? [applause] Um
[applause]
well if you think of a formal apology is
more important than the actual process
of abolition and the process of
worldwide suppression. If you think
that's more important, then I guess we
we could say the words.
>> These false binaries though, who's
saying that that's not important? We're
saying that's not enough as you yourself
agree.
>> What what I guess what I'm saying is I
think the act uh was was a costly
apology.
Uh but you want the words added. I I'm
sure we could add the words,
>> but they haven't. The British
government's refused to do that. In
fact, it tried to block the EU from
doing it earlier. Uh let's go to our
panel of experts who are waiting here to
come in. Uh Kojo Niger says it's just
not possible. It wasn't possible then.
It's not possible now. this isn't an
issue of morality or if it is it's about
getting slavery ended. We paid the price
to the slave owners. What's wrong with
that view?
>> I think that we always try to frame the
idea of reparations as though it's an
impossibility when in fact we see it
pretty prevalent within both
international and transnational justice
movements of the current moment. We can
look at not just the German reparations
paid towards victims of the Holocaust.
We can look at the German paying
reparations to the victims of the
genocide in modern day Namibia. and we
understand the mechanisms that could
allow for that ability to transfer um
resources over time to people who have
been the long-term victims. If we could
do that with the um compensation of the
uh enslavers with the slave compensation
act in 1837 which comes after the
emancipation act in 1834 then we
absolutely have the technology to be
able to do that in the current day.
>> Lawrence Goldman, do you disagree with
that?
>> Three points. One, in 183233, a wig
cabinet had to push for emancipation and
the slave holders in the Caribbean set
the price at 40 million. 40 million was
what they wanted and the wigs beat them
down to 20 million. Now, it was not
controversial. If you look at political
records, if you look at the
correspondents, nobody thought it was
controversial at all. That was the price
that had to be paid. And the British
were prepared. their government was
prepared. It It's a deal. Three. Time is
short.
>> Okay. Simply again to keep morality out
of this because sometimes you just have
to do things which are painful but not
in a moral framework. But secondly,
let's think about apologies for a
moment. And let me be a moralist for a
second. Okay? What would be what would
be the validity of an apology by people
who nothing to do with slavery, who live
generations after it ended, who live in
a multicultural society where tens of
millions of us were not even here. What
are we apologizing for? Something that
we never did. And who are we apologizing
to? People who were never slaves. It
would be empty. it would have no
significance. It would it would destroy
the idea of an apology.
>> Very very common and strong argument. I
I'm going to interrupt you before we get
to point three and say KJO, do you want
to respond to that point?
>> I think that when we talk about what
would be the value of acknowledging the
violence of transatlantic slavery and
also of trying to make reparative
justice, we are thinking about what
happens in the present, not just in the
past. I think that in the moment of a
changing world in which we have a
growing multipolarity, Britain is
looking to try and reestablish its
relationships with its former colonial
countries in the Commonwealth. Of
course, that um problem emerged when it
turned out that the um foreign office
had cenamed that trade strategy Empire
2.0. And so this is part of the myopia
that happens when we try to extend
ourselves into the currently changing
world without acknowledging the violence
and the pain of people we are then
trying to um facilitate relationship
[applause] with.
>> Let me bring in Ginda Bambra who's been
waiting patiently. Um Ginda Nigel makes
the point that empire is part of human
history. We talked about this earlier.
He also makes a point that slavery is
part of human history. He mentioned
quote unquote Islamic slavery and other
forms of slavery. What's your response
to that? What would you say?
>> I mean, well, I think there's a real
issue about the lack of specificity
about what is being talked about. It is
just not true that all societies had
forms of slavery that were equivalent in
any way. What emerges with the European
trade in human beings is a very distinct
form of slavery which involves the
transaction of human beings. So you have
forms of servitude and you have forms of
coerced labor in societies where there
weren't previously ideas of free labor.
What's distinct about the emergence of
cattle slavery with as the Europeans
undertake it is that what's happening in
Europe at the time is the emergence of
the idea of free labor. So to have free
labor at home, but to kidnap and enslave
populations elsewhere and to transact
them and that's a very distinct form
from any other type of surfom, servitude
or forms of bondage that exist in any
other part of the world.
>> So I I fully accept that there there
were different forms of slavery. I I
need to to ponder what you've said quite
understand the significance of it. What
I don't accept is that the the form of
enslavement that the Europeans engaged
in was was uniquely brutal. It was very
brutal. It wasn't uniquely so. Um and um
in terms of reparations that that to to
finger the British alone and it's only
the British or Europeans who are being
fingered is just unfair uh given uh the
fact that we abolished it, we suppressed
it, we we we paid for that and that that
no one no one is asking money from
Africa and and West African West West
Africans were involved in enslaving
other Africans at least from the 1500s
on.
very briefly you want to
>> the abolition of slavery was followed by
a century or more of indenture. So it's
not as if abolition was the end of the
story. So we often talk about abolition
as if it's the end of the story of
European involvement in the enslavement
of populations. Not only do we not talk
about enslavement within the Indian
Ocean world, but only focus on
transatlantic slavery. But we also don't
then look at the systems of indenture
that took millions of Indians and
Chinese to the Caribbean. Indenture is
not different to enslavement.
>> [applause]
>> Uh, morally speaking, indenture and
slavery are not the same thing.
>> Just on slavery though, before we before
I do want to go to the audience, you
could have written a book and said, I
think that we did a great job ending
slavery, which we did, but you I don't
know if this is just because it helps
you become a bestseller, but you had
this line, the tyranny of imaginary
guilt. You're a Christian theologian and
you're saying we shouldn't feel guilty
at all about 3 million Africans being
taken out of their homes and moved to
the Atlant across the Atlantic.
>> That's imag the guilt is imaginary. Why
can't we have guilt and also believe
everything you just said?
>> First of all, uh um we can only feel
guilt for something we did.
>> We did. We we did take 3 million people
out of Africa.
>> You and I didn't.
>> No, you and I didn't. I can lament what
some of our ancestors did. I can't feel
guilty for it.
>> So that mean Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
So, you're telling me with a straight
face, you don't take pride in Britain in
us defeating the Nazis in World War II?
>> Uh,
>> you've never taken pride in that.
[applause]
Uh, uh, I take pride in it. I I admire
the fact of what my
>> You take pride in it. It's not us.
>> Well, no, of course. I I can't I can't I
can't claim I I can't claim the credit
for having done that because I didn't.
My parents did. I didn't.
>> We as British people take pride
>> only indirectly.
>> So take guilt indirectly.
>> In terms of guilt
uh uh be uh because
you cannot be guilty for something you
didn't do. You can be responsible for
the effects. You can't be guilty for it.
>> But you can take pride in something you
didn't do. But you could take pride in
something you didn't do.
>> Um
metaphorically. So I I I pref I I I
prefer to talk I I prefer to use the
word admiration now.
>> Okay. But most British people take pride
in our win over the Nazis. Let's go to
the audience here in the Conway Hall. Uh
let's go to the lady in the third row.
>> Lord Bigger. You've spent much of your
career arguing for moral clarity. Now
that you've joined the House of Lords
after getting peership by Cammy Bandon,
leader of the Conservative Party, do you
worry that association might blur the
lines between your academic voice and
your political one?
[applause]
>> Good question. Is that something else to
think about?
>> Um, so I become I deliberately became
politically committed. Um um that that
doesn't mean to say that I've I've
abandoned my my mind or my conscience.
Um when when you're politically
committed uh you have to support things
you don't entirely agree with. Uh if I
disagreed with something sufficiently I
could either abstain or resign and I
would uh but it's part of the uh the
parliamentary game if you like that you
have to commit yourself to a party. You
don't agree with everything in the
party. It doesn't matter what which
party you commit yourself to. Um but uh
I think at this point in my life I want
to be committed rather than stand on the
sidelines and spectator as an academic.
Would you describe yourself as a
right-wing person?
>> Uh, no. I wouldn't actually. I regard
myself as a moderate person. People on
the far left regard me as far right.
>> Well, some of your critics have pointed
out that you spend a lot of time uh with
kind of Victor Orban affiliated groups
and that's not a great look when you're
talking about nationalism and history.
>> I absolutely reject any notion of
damnation by association. I associate
with all sorts of people. uh when I get
up get to stand up on a on a platform
that Victor Orbam may have shared in in
Washington and I get to stand in in in
London, you can be sure that I speak my
mind not
>> London and Washington. What about
Budapest?
>> I mean what's that got to do with I mean
Victor Orban lives in Budapest. What's
>> you you write in the book in Colonial
you say what has Victor Orban got to do
with me?
>> Yeah, exactly. What has he got to do
>> Well, you launched your book at a Victor
Orban funded think tank called the MCC
in Budapest the year before.
>> The director of the MCC is not Victor
Orban. the chair the chair of the board.
>> It's Balash.
>> Yes.
>> Not Victor.
>> He's the political dire.
>> No connection.
>> No connection between Balash Orban and
Victor Orban. No.
>> Balash Orban is the political director
of Victor Orban's prime ministerial
office.
>> But but but is not Victor Orban.
>> I didn't say he was.
>> Right. So, so, so I mean the MCC is an
educational
>> it's funded by the Orban government. The
New York Times has written many pieces
about how it's linked.
>> There's much about the Orban government
I disagree with. This project I think is
is very good. But it's strange to write
in the book, what has Victor Orban got
to do with me when you'd literally
spoken at an Orban funded think tank
alongside political director.
>> I just wanted to make the point when I
step on a platform, I speak my mind, not
anyone else's.
>> Fair enough. Okay, thank you for that.
Let's go back to the audience. Let's go
to the gentleman here in the front row.
>> We are we are focusing very much on how
the empire is viewed in this country
that but in countries like India,
colonial institutions are regularly
commemorated. These commemorations are
fully reported in India by all the press
but they're completely ignored in this
country and I'm asking why is it that
commemorations aren't ignored in this
country.
>> Your point being that there are a lot of
people in India who appreciate those
that colonial
>> whereas they do in foreign policy.
>> Well I'm going to put that question I'm
suspecting Nigel might agree with you on
that. I'm going to put that question to
god and do you want to respond uh that
actually a lot of Indians appreciate
what the British did.
>> I think Indians are probably the same as
Brits and that they don't know their
history very well. I mean one of the
things about British Empire is
[applause]
I mean we have so the arguments that
have been made we have to look at
history seriously and one of the things
that's missing in the in the the
conversation and in the books is really
this sense of connection between Britain
and India and the ways in which India
has funded so much of what exists within
Britain. So slavery has contributed but
so has colonialism in India and there's
a failure to recognize the extent to
which colonial and slave wealth has
actually built every institution in this
country that we're in. And I'd just like
to say one other thing one of the things
that we talked about in terms of you
know stuff happens in the past and
therefore we can't sort of address it in
the present. Well, if we go to Edmund
Burke and Edmund Burke's understanding
of society, he understood society as a
partnership, a partnership between the
living, the dead, and the not yet born.
And the institutions are what combine
the past, the present, and the future.
And if there are injustices in
institutions in the past, they manifest
as inequalities in the present. So, we
have to address those inequalities in
the present to make good the injustices
of the past.
>> Okay, let's go back to the audience.
[applause]
Let's go to gentleman in the blue shirt
and then I'll go to the there gentleman
there.
>> Given that uh the real rising empire in
the world at the moment is China and the
role that they're playing with African
countries. You talk about extracting
materials, rare earth, the sort of belt
and road initiative where they're
effectively making other states
indentured states.
>> You know who who's going to be demanding
reparations in 50 years time and from
whom?
>> I'm going to put that question to Kojo
if you don't mind. And do you want to
deal with that question?
>> This idea that the belt and road
initiative countries engaging with China
for development or engaging with Russia
for security is a result of their own
myopia and failure. I think we need to
think about why is it that they're
willing to engage with those countries
but not willing to engage with Britain.
The fact that we refuse to acknowledge
the colonial violence, we refuse to
offer a formal apology and we refuse to
recognize how damaging that history was.
I think that we need to think about
Britain's role of how do we reestablish
those relationships with those
countries.
>> We are almost out of time, but I did but
I did promise this lady here a question.
You're going to be the last question.
Apologies. Yeah.
>> Lord Bigger, you've argued that free
speech is under threat from what you
define as cancel culture. However, isn't
that phrase often used to dismiss
legitimate criticism? When does
accountability for one's worth stop
being censorship and rather starts being
responsibility?
>> So there's no doubt that that um u the
free expression of of certain views like
mine u um uh is canceled. It's been
canceled in my case three times this
year. I'm really glad that Medi has had
the likes of me on this platform. I I
don't think there should be censorship
within very broad legal uh um uh
confines. Um so uh the only way I can be
accountable is by saying what I think
and then you can respond. Um that's why
cancellation and and uh censorship is so
uh unhealthy because uh views don't get
challenged. we don't get to think
together and it's really important that
we have more or less civilized exchanges
where views that that we really don't
like. Uh we get to be confronted with
them and we get to be forced to think
about them and discuss them. Um so I'm
all in favor of accountability. I'm all
in favor of free speech um um except
within confines imposed by the law in
terms of forbidding the incitement of
racial hatred for example. But we should
have we should have a broad liberal
space for the uh open uh in good faith
exchange of ideas.
>> Well, I appreciate you letting me
challenge your ideas tonight. Uh we are
out of time. Nigel Bigger, thank you for
joining us on Headto-Head. Thank you to
our audience here in London's Conway
Hall. Thank you for your questions and
thank you to our panel of experts for
their insights. Uh appreciate you coming
on the show. Headtohead is over for now,
but it'll be back soon.